[Musica]
questa sera abbiamo sentito storie di
matematica fisica cybersecurity
tecnologia energia e io cosa c'entro io
sono alberto cavallari sono un
architetto e questa sera in contrasto
forse con le storie che abbiamo sentito
o forse proprio affinché le storie che
abbiamo sentito possano avere luogo io
questa sera vi parlerò della noia ecco
proviamo voi che siete in sala a pensare
le cose che mi danno noia e io ho
provato a riassumerle con dei disegnini
la prima è andare alle poste fare la
fila alle poste dire alla gente di stare
in fila alle poste la seconda è
pianificare meticolosamente un viaggio
prima di partire e la terza passare
l'aspirapolvere cosa abbastanza banali e
condivisibili però ce n'è un'altra che
oltre a darmi noia vi confesso mi fa
anche un po paura ed è la routine ora se
noi chiediamo a google la routine è
un'abitudine lentamente acquisita per
mezzo della pratica e dell'esperienza
più comunemente a proposito di una
monotona e deprimente consuetudine
quindi una ripetizione monotona e
deprimente
ora facciamo un indagine in sala e
tranquilli che nessuno verrà chiamato
sul palco quindi potete rispondere in
maniera serena
alzi la mano chi si può definire
pendolare quindi che deve muoversi da un
punto ha tendenzialmente all'abitazione
ad un punto b il luogo di studio o di
lavoro in maniera ripetuta e
continuativa prego
non vedo molto ma mi fido che l'abbiate
alzate
ritengo di essere in ottima compagnia
bene
come nella presentazione il pendolarismo
fa parte della fa parte della mia
routine della mia ripetizione e proviamo
a fare un paio di calcoli perché checché
se ne dica anche gli architetti sono in
grado di fare i calcoli
allora se noi prendiamo in
considerazione il periodo dal 2001 al
2021 il 2001 e iniziai a muovermi con il
treno per andare al liceo fino ad oggi
sono vent'anni e stimando circa 230
giorni all'anno al netto dei mesi
festivi del weekend e moltiplicando
questi per il viaggio di andata e il
viaggio di ritorno sono la bellezza di
9.200 viaggi ora se noi moltiplichiamo
questi 9.200 viaggi per i 40 minuti
nominali che l'azienda dei trasporti
dice che ci mette il mio viaggio e voi
sapete quanto siamo ottimisti ci in
questa stima sono
368mila minuti che convertiti in ore
sono 6.133 ore che sono la bellezza
continuativa di
255 giorni quindi
255 giorni della mia vita da pendolare
in vent'anni sono stati e come se io per
255 giorni continuativi avessi
continuato ad effettuare il solito
viaggio che noia direte voi lo dico
anch'io perché è infatti stiamo parlando
della noia
bene questa è stata un po la mia
reazione alla fine di questi calcoli e
dopo gli anni del liceo e dopo una
brillantissima carriera di ben sei mesi
in ingegneria inizia la facoltà di
architettura e l'obiettivo di uno dei
primi corsi era quello di redigere un
diario di viaggio ovvero un quaderno
dove mediante schizzi disegni appunti si
potessero ripercorrere i passi dei
grandi maestri dell'architettura del
novecento le corbusier frank lloyd
wright alvar aalto miss van der rohe
adolf loos lui cannes e via
questo
questa modalità diventa parte di me
tant'è che da quel momento io non mi
muovo senza una penna e un agenda ed è
diventata un po la mia coperta di linus
e mi accompagna sempre nei miei viaggi
sia nei miei mi aiuta
a combattere la noia di questi 9.200
viaggi e anche le altre mie esperienze
ovviamente le pagine si riempiono di
schizzi disegni appunti con l'ice frasi
pensieri citazioni
spunti che poi possono tornare utili per
i miei progetti attuali ad un certo
punto successe una cosa era il 2012 me
lo ricordo bene stavo tornando
abbastanza tardi dall'università e il
vagone era mezzo vuoto ma davanti a me
avevo un passeggero e lui era
completamente assorto dal telefono
allora dentro di me e scatta una sorta
di sfida dovevo riuscire a ritrarlo
senza farmi vedere voi vi immaginate il
mio stato di angoscia e di paura ero
sicuro che lui mi avrebbe beccato e
avrebbe detto scusa ma cosa stai facendo
beh mi misi lì è il risultato che ne
venne fuori fu questo un disegnino anche
abbastanza brutto direte voi ed è quello
che penso anch'io però la cosa che mi
stupì è che lui non si accorse
minimamente di niente quindi andrà
avanti in questa sfida i passeggeri
diventarono 2 4 8 10 20 era come se i
passeggeri assorti dallo schermo del
telefono e da un continuo movimento e di
scroll fossero continuamente estranei a
quello che gli succedeva intorno
bene in questi miei viaggi o ritratti
passeggeri più disparati un ritratto
passeggeri impegnati in importantissimi
e vitali col che probabilmente avevano a
cuore le sorti del mondo e che ci
tenevano a condividere con l'intero
vagone e poi passeggeri assorti in
importantissime sedute di meditazione
passeggeri rattrappiti dal freddo più
gelido nei mesi invernali e squagliati
completamente nei vagoni nei mesi estivi
e anche il contrario perché ogni tanto
la temperatura non è sempre regolata al
massimo e poi passeggeri che
affrontavano la città milano la
metropoli da capitale della moda in
tutta la loro eleganza e loro stile e
passeggeri che sono ancora un po in
cerca del loro stile non dialogo aperto
con lo stile ho documentato i passaggi
tecnologici passeggeri intenti a
districarsi dai fili delle delle
cuffiette passeggeri con cuffie più
grandi di loro e passeggeri che sembrano
intenti
teatrali ma che in realtà non solo delle
cuffie invisibili i passaggi
generazionali bambini in gita
adolescenti che probabilmente mi
associava loro perché proveniente
stavano anche copiando i compiti e le
generazioni più adulte e poi come vi
dicevo il porto sempre con me la mia
agenda e la mia penna e questo mi a
portarmi a mi ha consentito di
affrontare anche i viaggi e di poter
ritrarre le diverse culture di cui io
ero ospite
ovviamente ad un certo punto pausa come
tutte le nostre vite anch'io ho subito
una pausa anche i miei viaggi hanno
subito una pausa e dopo i mesi di pausa
forzata mi sono ritrovato a ritrarre
vagoni desolatamente vuoti i primi
passeggeri che penso più per necessità
che per volontà affrontavano i viaggi e
cercavano di interagire a prendere
confidenza con questi dispositivi di
protezione individuale e come ben potete
immaginare ora i passeggeri con la
mascherina sono sono la mia routine
tranne in alcuni svariati casi
bene questi passeggeri
la sono ormai raccolti in 20 agendine un
ipad e qualche foglio sparso e il conto
odierno perché è un viaggio sempre in
movimento ed i 715 disegni ma se ci
pensiamo bene sono 715 disegni che
ritraggono 715 volti che sono 700 15
persone che dentro di loro hanno ognuno
la sua storia ognuno la sua storia che
probabilmente è tanto interessante
quanto quelle che abbiamo ascoltato
ascoltato qua oggi e questo mi ha fatto
pensare perché c'è una contraddizione di
fondo se ci pensate il tema del ted sono
le connessioni e noi con questi telefoni
siamo abbiamo la possibilità di essere
connessi a 100.000 chilometri di
distanza possiamo seguire le evoluzioni
tecnologiche e il l'approdo di nuovi
strumenti sui vari pianeti o molto più
banalmente possiamo seguire le gesta
dell'influenza dei di nostro riferimento
però questa cosa ci disconnette
completamente da che abbiamo intorno e
quindi non riusciamo a percepire che una
persa davanti a noi a meno della del
metro della distanza sociale che quello
che avviene nei vagoni con uno strumento
anti tecnologico come la penna el
agendina sta effettuando un'operazione
anti tecnologica come un ritratto
e questa cosa mi ha portato a pensare a
delle cose ad imparare delle cose che
questa sera volevo avere il lusso di
condividere con voi la prima è che la
noia non sempre ha un'accezione negativa
anzi tante volte essa stessa portatrice
di quell'energia che abbiamo dentro la
seconda è che sta tutto a noi sta a noi
cambiare lo sguardo e saper cogliere
dentro la nebbia della noia le più
grandi occasioni la terza è che anche i
disegni brutti come quelli che avete
visto stasera sono capaci di portare
delle delle storie e la quarta forse la
più importante che anche noi esattamente
come quei disegnini brutti dobbiamo
forse a volte accantonare la tendere
alla perfezione del contenitore ma
essere fieri del nostro contenuto grazie
a
e un'ultima cosa
la prossima volta state più attenti
durante i viaggi grazie
[Applauso]